i will now start leading or trying to
uh moderate the discussion section
between
among the four panelists
um so the first thing that i'll do is
i'll try to i'll do my best to summarize
the four uh the four talks that we had
uh in this session
um
try to
see what there is in common what
overlaps there are and how we can
benefit
uh
the bioinformaticians that are uh
watching us here
and how we can
uh stimulate i think a a community
uh that is open to foster collaboration
and to talk about science and develop
this field of bioinformatics so in the
first talk we heard about mathematical
modelling of an interplay between
flaviviruses and their natural defective
genomes the second part
was about reconstructing
dynamic
dynamic potential for objective
observations of multiple features data
like single cell expression in for
differentiation of cells
aging of organisms
and now how omics and
biomedical data is used to understand
metagenomics and
how that can be
also applied
for
what dr uh brodsky
told us very very well very
interestingly the
haplotypes and the haplotypes of
different
[Music]
viruses and phylogenomics
uh in the second talk of dr rauhan
andino we had mathematical modeling for
public health
we have a very interesting
talk where he led us through the the use
of different bioinformatics uh
techniques and models
to understand also many aspects of
genomic variation in the in the
viral
in the viral genetic material
particularly uh
we are all interested here in the
current pandemic so the these mutations
and
the
role the biological role that these
mutations may
uh
have in
for instance
the
spread and a specificity between the h2
receptor and the spike protein in the
for i am talking obviously about the
about the star cov2 virus
and then uh the the third in the third
talk we had a very
great description of single cell
sequencing and also the application of
numerous bioinformatics
tools
in the
in the platform that is available uh by
uh pine biotech and that was that by doc
by dr julia panoff
finally we had dr uh the sharma uh lead
us through this very interesting tour on
extremophiles and astrobiology there
there's a
a huge uh field for disc discussion in
my opinion about the biotechnological
applications of both viruses
extremophiles uh
single cell sequencing and also the
algorithms for
uh studying all of these uh
all of these subjects
so these uh these are uh
we have a common molecular biology
background in all of these
fields but at the same time we are
talking about very different fields of
application
therefore uh different kinds of back of
the grounds different kinds of people
are necessary to advance
and uh provide and provide the benefits
in areas such as medicine computer
science and communication we have seen
in the in the past year
how communication information and
education industries adopted adapted
quickly to the reality of uh distancing
that is that was imposed by the sar
steel victor
from this adaptation exercise we see
that
there needs to be
an effort uh due to the
we see that clearly because of the
pandemic
and that has not ended yet in many
countries
and we see that we all
we all need to have some sort of
adaptation to a technology driven world
or culture
so this dynamic imposes a need for
education and here we are uh
talking we want to talk about
bioinformatics education
a need for collaboration and also a need
for uh communication so i wanted to
again introduce our speakers dr rau
andino is a
microbiologist and immunologist at the
university of california san francisco
uh dr leonid brodsky is a professor of
bioinformatics and biostatistics and the
director of the tauber bioinformatics
research center at the university of
haifa israel dr shiladitya desharma is a
professor at the institute of marine in
environmental technology at the
university of maryland school of
medicine and julia dr julia panov is an
associate director for the tauber
bioinformatics research center in israel
i hope that the panelists will provide
us with their perspective on how to
navigate this changing dynamic of data
and algorithms in biological research
so uh i have some general questions here
but where is all of this data revolution
taking us
and how
what have we learned from the
pandemic what have we learned that we
need to adapt to this
to this word that is more and more
computational driven
i can
start just break the eyes here but just
say
just say that um you know
i think your
your question is uh directed to an
answer so i'm gonna try to get that
answer and that is you know the pandemic
demonstrated that um it's important to
uh collaborate and integrate and you can
start seeing now papers that has 30
authors on it
and i think that's interesting um you
know i don't know exactly what is the
reason for this to happen but in my
personal experience pandemic has been
very disruptive very disruptive
in a positive sense you know it
make us stop doing what we were doing
and start focusing on a different
problem
and starting to interact with people
that normally don't work in virology
and that has been a tremendous
experience for us you know at least two
or three new collaborators that i would
never thought i would collaborate with
it was important now how this omix
you know
gets there is what we've been
discussing uh before
i think that the important thing and i
think
in part the pine
biotech
platform
help us to do that
is to have a friendly interface
in which
uh informations
an experimentalist
can converge
i think at the end of the day you know
like it happened to me with leonid
having a coffee in a nice place
uh
it it has
you know a tremendous
um
effect
transformative effect but i think having
a platform an interface that is friendly
for both experimentalism and and
information is the next step in which
this information can be exchanged
using you know on the the situation that
we are right now that maybe we're not
able to travel as much as we used to
yeah so
if i could jump in for for a minute
um
so
to me
the difference between
bioinformatics and and biology is sort
of semantic because the real difference
is between
data
and
knowledge
and
both
bioinformatics and experimental work can
lead to data
but we need to transform that into our
understanding whether it be covid or the
evolution of life
and so i think a meeting like this is
really very
very nice to have people looking at
everything from cancer virology
obviously we're all concerned about
covet and it's the overriding concern
around the world
but as i mentioned the uh tom brock
just uh
dude
was doing discovery science by going to
yellowstone and looking at
uh you know thermal ponds for microbes
and isolated thermos aquaticus from
which we
uh purified uh attack polymerase and and
then you know
kerry mullis and all the uh developed
pcr and uh you know maybe maybe pcr is
not as important for sequencing but it
has been for very long and it's probably
still going to be critical for
diagnostics
so that's where the interdisciplinary
collaboration
is so important i think and especially
going forward because there's so much
potential
can i add uh to that talk so you
mentioned tac polymerase how it has been
so important for the development of
sequencing uh back in the day when
sanger was more used
than now
uh and you can see there how uh these
extremophiles are very important for
other areas
and i was i also wanted to highlight for
instance the
isolation of
reverse transcriptases from viruses
so uh
transforming for instance rna into cdna
and being able to sequence that is
is on
i'm not entirely sure if it's correct to
say that if that it's only possible
because there are uh virologists that
developed the understanding and the
basic understanding of molecular biology
on
the virus and how they use their enzymes
and all of these
processes so this really
this is key nowadays for us to be able
to sequence
rna first to be able to look at
gene expression just like
julia looks at
rna rna
rna-seq
and i think many many of you also
do other sorts of sequencing as
well right if if i can jump in again i'm
sorry uh so
so in addition i think there are
technologies that maybe are are
considered old now but they were the
mainstay of uh molecular biology like
restriction enzymes
you know nathan smith won ann arbor won
the nobel prize for that in the 1970s
and it was the reason why we have
molecular biology today it would not
have been possible and of course more
recently they're they're crispers
and all of those came about through
discoveries
uh
resulting from virologists and
microbiologists
interested in different
types of
microbes
and uh
analyzing their biology and
or the in the the example that you gave
geo on
the reverse transcriptases and david
baltimore and people like that so yeah
so i think that that it's it's really uh
important to be able to do the basic
science on
what is i consider a natural resource i
mean the the microbes and the viruses
that are out there
i know that some of them cause disease
but they're really a natural resource
and they have so many amazing
molecules and features
that we can then utilize for various uh
useful applications
right if i can jump as well
not to
kidnap the discussion but i want to
emphasize uh the thing because
i'm too mean it's obvious and i think
for all every scientist it's obvious
that what the reason why we are at this
stage here is because you know
dpt has played an important role in
advancing science nobody could
anticipate that somebody study yogurt
will discover crispr right and
and i think
the wonderful ideas to look at the micro
organisms world because there's a lot of
information there in my mind the problem
then this is
gets a little political here but i think
the problem is
that the
people that are leaders in science right
now
they are trying to save as much money as
possible and demonstrate that the money
that is invested in science
every dollar results in an important
result in a paper
and that is completely wrong
i think the science has to be wasted the
money has to be wasted in science 95
of the money should go
doing good science but most of this
result should not result in anything
except to say my idea was wrong if
that's what popper you know will say you
know you the only thing you can do is
prove yourself wrong
but the five percent that does not
result in something negative will pay
for everything 10 times
and i think that is such an important
concept and we need to appeal to the
congress appeal to the leaders and say
come on
you guys invest in phages invest in
bacteria
you know do that kind of things because
you don't you don't know what's going to
be the brilliant mind coming up with a
new algorithm
[Music]
talking about uh how we have generated
so much data in the past years i think
we have developed a lot the molecular
biology and the biochemistry and all of
these what i call
wet lab experiments and now there's so
much data out there
i think we're really at the point and i
think elia was sharing earlier today how
i
i came to my phd program
without bioinformatics background
without the programming background
and i realized during my studies how
important it is
to develop these
coding skills these bioinformatics
skills
as a scientist as a student so i wanted
to ask
dr brodsky
what do you think are important uh
how do you think a person that does not
have necessarily a background in
mathematics or statistics
or
programming how can
how can we uh
develop uh
that that important background which is
the ability to look at data that has
already been generated that is sitting
maybe on uh databases that can be
accessed for instance now we have the
gis say database which has uh i think at
this point it should be like three
million uh sequencing files available
for a covid sarco v2
and
we have
databases such as tcga the gene
expression honeyboos and
there are initiatives in the united
states in europe and in japan that store
these data that that have been produced
along these years and
how
how can we
gain more
experience
on
analyzing this data
okay um
from my perspective
there are two
actually
major
major directions to do that
one is
new opportunities which new technologies
computational technologies are giving us
for instance just recently this
google
artificial intelligence based prediction
of protein
structures
generation of millions
of protein structures
this is completely new opportunity for
us which can be used
another thing is
is
interface
human
friendly
user interface
so with friendly user interface
any
theoretically any person in any
biologist or any student can operate
with databases and with
sophisticated algorithms
naturally
as raw said
actually this is this this is a way for
normal to collaborate actually to go
over it because
previously
biologist is just
just asking
a bioinformatician to do computational
work
and this is problematic because
the
this bioinformatician
doesn't know biology or not interested
in the project and and so on
if
the biologist itself
can work
themselves
can work
with
with a platform with some computational
platform and do
his analysis computational analysis
himself
it will be great
and
actually
the same approach in education
i think is also very promising
so this combination of new opportunities
from computational technologies
and
user-friendly interface interface
between computer and
human
are two
key features for
for success
for success implication and success
even in the research
thank you
julia do you want to add
something
no
okay i was just going to
say yes
it is very important to
have the coding skills i would say to be
able to analyze and process uh
sequencing data and i was going to i
also wanted to ask how
how is it i don't know if can you have
any experience in uh maybe julia you
have a little bit of experience in uh
providing the the tools for the user
providing the the tool that the user is
going to
run their analysis in how is uh and i
don't know if you have a coding
background
so so my uh so maybe i'll answer uh so
my background is in neurobiology and i
have been doing bioinformatics
work and analyzing data
providing tools for the user
requires i think again
collaboration of many parties
uh collaboration of software engineers
on one side mathematicians who actually
come up with algorithms
uh
and also uh biologists who will be the
end user of this tool and who will try
to use it and fail many times before
this tool becomes actually uh
usable and user friendly so from our
experience at least
it takes a while
from the tool to become
actually user friendly and of course
another
important aspect i think
is being able to communicate to the end
user how exactly this tool is supposed
to be used giving him enough
not only just information or guides but
also examples of
projects
and questions that this tool or this
a number of tools um that we call
pipeline
can answer
in different combinations of course
so
from from
my experience from our experience it
seems like uh it's again a question of
collaboration
uh
good communication between different
uh people and with different expertise
that sometimes speak
different languages
so
so also
combining everybody together
is
is another challenge that has to be met
before the tool becomes really
usable
and becomes
becomes something that other people can
actually use
perfect
i think i should uh
i would like to add in relation to
education
uh that actually this is
self-education is becoming
self-education
this is a project this is a flexible
platform and the user which is trying to
to solve the problem with platform
how to make the platform flexible and
which will cover all
all possible
aspects of the project
this is this is the question for the
world
perfect thank you so much
i
i generally try to make
connections possibly where
people do not see
so i find it really interesting that dr
the sarma
works with astrobiology and the
development of life
on earth as a result from the
interaction of earth with the cosmos
and i find really interesting how uh
previous to
uh
how
molecules evolve to form uh form a cell
and it's really interesting that uh
julia you work with single cell
sequencing and how that uh is
informative about the interaction of uh
virus with human cells so there is a
question here
about single cell sequencing what uh
i think we should give some background
to
the maybe the comparisons of single cell
and book rna sequencing uh someone asked
uh
how does the pi how do how do pipelines
for analysis of single cell rna
sequencing differs
from uh book rna sequencing
okay so maybe uh i can take that and
so yeah the pipelines differ actually
quite a lot uh in bulk rna sequencing
you're dealing usually with
up to hundreds of samples at one time
uh i haven't seen a lot of projects that
deal with thousands and when you
analyze the single cell or single nuclei
data
of course
each cell is considered a
sample
so
you have thousands if not tens of
thousands
of
cells
which
also come in bulk so there is a big
question of normalization of data
and
and
batch correction between different
donors for example
and different preparation methods
[Music]
of the actual uh
samples
so
and also single cell or single nuclei
[Music]
sequencing can be divided into two parts
the first part is actually getting to
the
expression table
which is much more complicated because
you have
these barcodes and depending on the
technology actually used and machines
for sequencing actually used you either
have only cell barcodes or you have
barcodes
barcodes that uh
are for cells and barcodes for
um
each mrna so this is uh one uh problem
that or challenge that needs to be
addressed
and then of course uh different
challenges uh remain such as uh batch
correction and normalization of data
between samples between and when here i
mean samples is just donors or
or tissues
and
and then
a big bottleneck and a challenge is
annotation of different cell types
or different clusters of cell and
actually understanding what these cells
are
is another challenge
that does not exist in bulk rna
okay
thank you so much and another question
that i saw in the chat uh was for dr
desharma uh wha how can we transfer a uh
a gene
from uh
how can you transfer extremophile gene
in a heterogeneous system
i guess the question is how can we clone
the gene in in the mammalian cell for
instance
right um
so uh there's actually uh that's
actually fairly straightforward because
the
most of the extremophilic
genes don't have introns and they're
pretty straightforward to express
um
the
i think uh the more difficult thing is
to set up a genetic system in the
extremophile which is what we were able
to do with the halo archaeon
but um in terms of expressing proteins
in either in e coli or in mammalian
cells they use the same genetic code
they are
uh maybe the proteins are more acidic
ice but the pan genome provides uh genes
that are not present anywhere else so
whether you're doing metagenomics
or whether you're doing single cell
genomics or whether you're doing uh more
traditional classical genome sequencing
the genes that you obtain are
potentially valuable
and um you you you uh addressed that
point a bit earlier and i was just
thinking then
that
it used to be that students
it was necessary for students to
generate data to analyze
of course i'm talking about the last
century so pardon my
my age but um
you know um
there are just there's just such an
avalanche of data and this is why we're
talking about bioinformatics
what i'm afraid of is with 10 to the 12
cells and the continuing decrease in
in sequencing technology and also
development of meta sequencing and meta
transcriptomics and so on
the the uh the rate of
production of data is not going to
decline so it just becomes really
important for how we're going to sort
through all of this data to convert it
into useful products and into knowledge
and so one of those is to express
proteins and there have been projects
even at nih in the past
of trying to identify the functions of
unknown genes by
a pipeline of expression
but those projects have not uh maybe
maybe
raul might know better about it i have
not seen those types of projects
continuing and it just
it bothers me because there is just such
a resource it's a natural resource
that's out there
for the taking but we need to allow
students to come in and
sort through it and pick through it and
find what's useful and express that in a
mammalian cell or
yeast or wherever
if i jump again i can jump a minute to
comment on a couple things you know one
is
something that um uh you said um
about
information
um could yield very beautiful pictures
and complex pictures that impress people
but doesn't necessarily takes you closer
to knowledge
um and the connection to knowledge is is
so important this this exercise having a
clear path and you know to understand
and
um go through this data to really learn
something new and that's something that
um julia chas say that i i really like
is um you're getting data from
different patients and you need to
normalize that right and that is because
this issue of noise is so
relevant in bioinformatics there is
millions and millions of sequence but
those sequences do not represent the
same thing because the sequence were
obtained um differently from different
patients
with different platform the technical
noise and the biological noise could
really impede to see the signal
and i would
challenge you know our
young audience here that i
the the in biology but in science in
general
in order to see something what you need
to do is reduce the noise if you want to
see a start in a telescope you need to
polish your lens such that there is no
imperfections on the images so you can
recognize a new start i think it's the
same thing here you need to get noise to
ratio no no noise to signal ratios
in a way that allows you to see the
things that you want to see sometimes
you need to know what you're looking for
but um
i think this issue of noise is is
critical and i i think it's part of this
by the exercise in bioinformatics
the other thing i wanted to just mention
is that i'm so pleased to be part of
this panel because in a way it's very
different group of people working in
very different things
but there is common things which is
um
often we study viruses and we learn
something is using for it used for
sequencing
often we study bacteria and we learn
something else that was very useful for
something else and i think it has a
you know over themed here and i would
say you know this idea of
beneficial microorganisms
is a very fertile ground for
bioinformatics and to learn that and the
last thing i wanted to say sometimes
when i was very young i was very
um afraid of approaching people that had
been established
and they you know run centers and they
handle millions of dollars or whatever
but i have a message for the young
people here don't be afraid we are
eager to contact you eager to work with
you either eager to
um
collaborate in a way learn together i
think that would be great and if you
know
if this happened in this symposium that
would be successful right signal of
success
let me add that in my from my
perspective bioinformatics is becoming
three-dimensional
but structural things are extremely
important for instance this blast story
which
presented us
orthologs through blast
it would be three-dimensional plus
local similarities which may be also
very important
to deal with huge amount of
three-dimensional structures which are
generated by
artificial intelligence problems
this is a challenge